this is a production of cornell
university
um i'm talking you i'm
speaking to you today though from my
home and roughly where that yellow star
is where i work in an
urban and regional food systems lab
this means that the farmers that we work
with
are very diverse in their
scope and practices but our research
broadly supports
farmers that are serving small-scale
regional markets across the upper
midwest
i also wanted to mention here that
wisconsin is also
home to the two working public care
readers in the state
and then in the nation rather and we're
really lucky to be able to work with
them on this project as well
so in order to meet the needs of the
farmers we work with who value
things like flavor and weed
competitiveness as well as open
pollinated varieties
we're interested in being able to use
germplasm from the usd carrot collection
in order to introduce traits that are
interest to us
the carrots in this collection are
relatively unstructured and carrot
itself is
an outcrossing diploid um
we are also hoping that the approach
that we're taking can serve as kind of a
case study
or a proof of concept approach for other
groups that are interested in using
germplasm collections
in breeding but need methods to be able
to do so deliberately and efficiently in
order to be
successful uh whatever the size of the
program
before i begin to talk about the
approach that we're using
i did want to touch just briefly on one
of the traits that we're interested in a
little bit more in depth
because i'll be referencing it again
throughout the talk and so canopy height
is
simply the measurement between the soil
and the top of the longest
petiole and we're interested in this
because it's positively correlated with
weed competitiveness
weed competitiveness which is something
that's really important to a lot of our
growers many of whom
are organic um and spend a lot of time
and effort especially earlier in the
season
uh managing weeds in their field this is
a phenotype we're able to
easily measure uh so we have methods
both for whole
plot phenotype being in the field and
then using barcode
barcode rulers and scanners we can
quickly do single plant phenotyping in
the lab as well
and now i'm going to discuss a little
bit about our approach
and we so we're interested in
using genomic prediction and broadly
genomic assisted selection
in order to quickly identify useful
germplasm
from a collection while minimizing the
need for
extensive field screening and with this
work we're really drawing on two sources
of inspiration
the first is that of core collections
now
usually these were um and this was uh
these are methods used
um that have been used to reduce the
size of collections that need to be
screened in the field
um typically they've been based in
phenotypes
or passport information with the
increasing accessibility
of low-cost markers however many
germplasm curators
are able to genotype the entire
collections making them amenable to
things like genomic prediction uh over
the last five years or so there has been
an
increased interest in using genomic
prediction injury in pleasant
collections but most of these studies
have been based in simulations
so what we really want to do is directly
compare phenotypic and genomic assisted
selection by developing
breeding populations using different
methods and then
taking them into the field
so just really briefly one slide on the
prediction
models we're using these are kinship
based methods in which we're building
models
by regressing phenotypes on markers in
order to calculate reading values of
untested accessions
and here's our experimental design we
are comparing
three different selection strategies uh
two different flavors of genomic
assisted election
against phenotypic selection and then
for each of these we're taking five
highly ranked accessions for each
strategy trait combination you'll see
harsh flavors on the screen where
um i don't have time to talk about that
today
but it's another thing that we're really
interested in and each of these
accessions is being crossed to two
popular inbreds which can be thought of
as either biological replicates or kind
of like a tester
um and then these are progressed to f
the f2 generation
so the phenotypic selection is serving
as kind of our current standard approach
using data from hancock wisconsin
a couple years ago the first flavor of
the
genomic selection we're determining the
genomic reading values
strategy in which we're using available
reading program data to calculate
reading values for untested accessions
i know i'm kind of racing through these
i'm more than happy to talk more
in detail about these strategies later
in the chat
and then finally we are also working
with the genomic training population
strategy
and which were in which we identified a
genetically representative training
population
which we then phenotyped in our target
environment this one maximized the
relationship between the
test and the training population which
um
can dramatically increase predictive
accuracy of models but it did require an
extra year of phenotyping before
breeding could begin
next i'm going to talk about just some
of the results we've been able to
achieve so far
obviously the main thrust of this work
is going to be
the comparison of breeding populations
and
i'm really glad to report we just got
approval to actually have a field season
this year which wasn't
clear a few weeks ago so while we have
some pilot data we're going to be able
to dramatically
increase that next year by doing a
replicated trial of these breeding
populations and measuring them for the
traits we're interested in
as we were developing our genomic
training population strategy we also
uh were able to test different
parameters of the training population
uh using cross validation so what we
looked at was both composition and also
relative size
compared to the total collection which
is what you see here
and then finally and this has become
somewhat of a pet project of mine
uh we're beginning to analyze intra
accession diversity
so observationally we note a fair degree
of heterogeneity within a given
accession
and i think moving forward the success
of this type of approach is going to
rest not only on improving strategies to
exploit variation between accessions but
also
methods to quantify
and track diversity within accessions as
well
so in closing
we believe that genomic assisted
selection can help small programs
use genetic resources more effectively
but what we're finding is that high
prediction accuracy
seems to require large training
populations
[Music]
but even moderate accuracy still may be
useful to programs who really just need
to reduce the number of accessions that
they're screening
and our future will work we'll
compare phenotypic and genotypic
selection in more detail
and we'll continue to track enter
accession diversity
with that um i'd like to thank people
who have
really been about invaluable to this
work um and i can take any questions
thank you
great thank you so much ko um i guess
we'll be
taking questions there's nothing in the
chat
so if you want to go ahead and raise
your hand and you can ask a question
uh looks like hannah uh hannah jeffrey
has a question
um you can go ahead and meet yourself
anna
thank you my question is about how
large do you think your training
populations will need to be in the
future
and what kind of statistical modeling
have you
implemented to try to predict what size
it will have to be
um
sure thank you for that question um
can you still hear me i'm not sure what
i'm looking at right now
um okay thank you yeah so
we saw a pretty dramatic improvement in
prediction accuracy
when we increased the size of our
training populations relative to the
total size of the collection
so i'm seeing another question here how
many germplasm do you work with
um and we were using about 470
cultivated accessions within the
germplasm collection
um and then the training population that
we phenotyped was 10
of that size which is consistent with
previous literature that looked at um
core collections that were roughly 10
the size of the total collection
and i think what's interesting is how
dramatically
accuracy did increase when we increased
the relative size so
jumping from 10 to 20 percent had
um had a large effect on prediction
accuracy
um and then so and then the second part
of your question is how
did we look at that um
that is correct yes yeah so
the one uh graph in the results section
that i showed
um showed how we so we had
a
data set of accessions for which we had
data for and we
used cross-validation to mask uh a
percentage of that that served as our
test population and then used
uh as the and then use the remaining as
the training population in order to
predict the
the the test group and we were able to
do that many times with many different
training populations
of a given size calculated in the same
way
in order to discover that
in order to calculate the mean and
variance
of accuracy thank you very much
it's helpful for me as a as a student
sure yeah uh i guess you answered how
many germplasms so
uh mark sorrells would you like to
unmute yourself and ask for a question
yeah thanks for your talk um aren't your
phenotypes confounded by the percent
heterozygosity in individual plants
um the shorter answer is probably
uh right now we're working with single
genotypes
per accession and this is an outcrossing
species so there's
a degree of heterozygosity with
um within accessions and what i found
um with some preliminary analysis is
that
that
level of heterozygosity also varies
across successions so i think uh future
work it's going to be really important
to follow up with some of that and
be able to account for a percent
heterogeneous heterozygosity
in our predictions
this has been a production of cornell
university
on the web at cornell.edu